Hey guys, it's Jan here!
I've been to see Batman v Superman: Dawn of
Justice and I've got lots of thoughts on the
movie.
But before I get to those, I wanna let you
know about a great giveaway I've got for a
very cool Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice:
The Art of the Film hardback book.
It'll be on my BvS Easter Egg video, so make
sure you subscribe and I'll add a link to
that video here when it's ready!
Ok, the big-screen schedule that DC has set
themselves, with solo movies and team-ups
like Justice League, is very ambitious, and
before seeing Batman v Superman I did wonder
if DC was trying to run before they could
walk, and whether they were rushing too much
to keep up with Marvel, who took more time
to build up their big-screen empire with a
shed-load of movies and a massive universe
of characters and worlds.
However, now I've seen Batman v Superman,
I feel that DC's ambition looks like it could
pay off rather nicely.
In BvS, they successfully introduce Ben Affleck's
Batman, and they give us a taste of what we
can expect from Gal Gadot's Wonder Woman movie
too.
There is certainly a hell of a lot to fit
into this film, what with all the elements
we expect of a Superman movie and a Batman
movie having to have their moment.
Not to mention the pointers to various members
of the Justice League, which are somewhat
shoehorned in.
Still, DC's world and franchise-building feels
like it's off to a decent start and I have
my fingers crossed that will continue in future
films.
I can definitely get on board with Ben Affleck's
believably world-weary rendition of the Dark
Knight, and it will certainly help wipe his
Daredevil a little further from my memory.
In fact, Affleck's presence on screen puts
Henry Cavill's Superman firmly in the shade.
I look forward to seeing Batfleck in a solo
movie, along with more of Jeremy Irons' sardonic
turn as Alfred.
As for Gal Gadot, I enjoyed her appearance
as Wonder Woman and it's certainly piqued
my interest for her solo outing next year.
But when it comes to Jesse Eisenberg's Lex
Luthor, I am not a fan.
It feels like he's taken his Social Network
turn as Mark Zuckerberg and dialled the tics
up to 11 in the misguided hope of pulling
off a performance as memorable as Heath Ledger's
Joker.
Sadly for us, he does not.
Cuts could definitely have been made to the
film's 2 and a half hour runtime, including
one especially ridiculous cameo, a plot-holey
subplot, and a needlessly-repeated flashback
that feels like the director and writers shouting
to us, 'hey, idiots, I know you have the memory
of a goldfish, so here's that bit you saw
earlier that you need to remember now to understand
this bit!'
Having said that, the script by Argo screenwriter
Chris Terrio and David S Goyer mostly moves
along well, and they deal with Batman's already
super-familiar origin story very neatly indeed.
And I really liked the way the film cleverly
links back to the events of Man of Steel,
giving us a completely new angle on what happened.
But overall, I felt that the reasons for Batman's
dislike of Superman were better established
than the reasons for Superman's dislike of
Batman.
There's no denying that BvS is a dark and
gritty film, but compared to Man of Steel,
you can sense they've made a concerted effort
to include more humour in the script.
Some of those efforts pay off nicely, though
a number fail to land, just as they did in
Superman's first outing.
Let me be clear on this: I do not need or
want DC to replicate Marvel's formula, but
remember that even amongst the darkness of
Nolan's and Burton's Batman movies, there
was still a spark of wit.
There are some incredible and exciting action
sequences throughout, and director Zack Snyder
takes his time to build up to the big battle
advertised in the main title, which for me
was a plus as it allowed time to build both
tension and the characters' antagonism rather
than racing to the main event too quickly.
Props to stunt co-ordinators Damon Caro and
Tim Rigby and their stunt teams for their
work throughout, as well as sound editor Scott
Hecker and his department especially for their
standout work during the action sequences.
How much you enjoy a certain part of the action
will depend on what you think of wholly CG
creations that feel like riffs on the Hulk
meets King Kong via Godzilla and Ray Harryhausen's
creatures.
BvS is pretty quickly cut by editor David
Brenner who keeps the pace up nicely through
most of the movie.
And there's some interesting use of slow-mo,
though in a few scenes it gets taken a bit
too far.
Still, I was glad that this time there wasn't
so much shaky-cam or the incessant zooming
in, zooming out, and zooming back in again
we had in Man of Steel, which at times in
that movie made me feel like I was watching
an episode of 24.
In terms of the look of the film and its sets,
I can't fault the work of production designer
Patrick Tatopoulos, Art Director Troy Sizemore
or Set Decorator Carolyn Loucks and their
teams who manage to create distinctive environments
for Batman, Superman, and Lex Luthor.
One of my biggest bugbears about BvS though
is the music.
It's incredibly overbearing and bombastic,
and feels like it's constantly trying to take
over each scene, especially during dramatic
moments and action sequences.
The score's by Hans Zimmer, who scored Nolan's
Batman trilogy, and Junkie XL, who composed
the scores for Mad Max: Fury Road and Deadpool.
As fantastic as their work is on other movies,
what they did here just does not work, to
the point where it takes you out of the film
and endlessly batters you about the head.
I really hope they change things up for future
DC outings.
So, to sum up, Batman v Superman: Dawn of
Justice is a super-powered, super-packed affair
that brings plenty to the comic book movie
table.
Is it perfect?
No, of course, it's not, far from it.
But it's also far from being a disaster, and
there's definitely much to like about it,
not least Zack Snyder and cinematographer
Larry Fong's visual flair, some incredible
action sequences, Ben Affleck's Batman, and
Gal Gadot's Wonder Woman.
In fact, I much preferred it to Man of Steel.
Overall, BvS gives me hope for the nascent
DC Extended Universe.
Fingers crossed they live up to that.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice gets 3
out of 5 Flicks.
Now, I'd love to know what you think of Batman
v Superman!
Do you think DC got it right?
And are you excited for the Justice League
and Wonder Woman solo movie?
Let me know in the comments below!
Coming up next will be my Batman v Superman
full easter egg video, my spoiler review of
the top 5 WTF moments, and some cool behind-the-scenes
secrets about the making of the movie.
Those videos and more will all be in my Batman
v Superman playlist, which you'll find a link
to here.
And you might also want to check out my Daredevil
Season 2 videos with easter eggs, top moments
and review here too.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!